OUGHT BE ALLOWED.
NOW HE'S ATTEMPTED TO JUMP AT
THE PAYGRADE HERE AND I WAS A
REACTION, FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR,
TAMMY BRUCE.
FOX AND FRIENDS WEEKEND COHOST,
PETE HEGSETH.
GOOD TO SEE YOU BOTH.
THE INTERESTING THING IS THERE
IS THE ONE ISSUE THEY WANT TO
GET RID OF TRUMP.
THEY ARE WILLING TO LIE AND DO
ANYTHING AND EVERYTHING TO DO
THAT AND COORDINATE EVEN
MESSAGES WITH THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY BUT THEN THEY
ARE SUPPORTING THIS IN EXCHANGE.
I KNOW THERE'S OTHER STUFF
COMING OUT AS IT RELATES TO CNN
THIS WEEK.
I'M AN INVESTIGATIVE REPORTER,
THAT'S PART OF BEING A TALK SHOW
HOST.
MY QUESTION TO YOU IS THIS WILL
DESTROY THE COUNTRY WE KNOW.
I DON'T SEE HOW AMERICA SURVIVES
THE NEW GREEN DEAL WITH
94 TRILLION AT MEDICARE FOR ALL
AND NO PRIVATE INSURANCE
AUCTION.
THAT'S JUST THE ESTIMATES.
>> YOU'RE CORRECT AND THE THING
THAT ALL OF THESE ISSUES HAVE IN
COMMON IS A DISDAIN FOR THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
IT'S A CONTEMPT FOR OUR ABILITY
TO UNDERSTAND OUR LIVES AND TO
MAKE OUR OWN DECISIONS AND TO
REALIZE WHAT FREEDOM REALLY IS,
THAT WE CAN BE TRUSTED WITH
FREEDOM, THAT WE ARE DECENT
PEOPLE, THAT WE IN FACT MAKE
BETTER DECISIONS IN GOVERNMENT.
ALL OF THESE DECISIONS,
SOCIALISM IS AN OLD DEAD, TIRED
IDEA.
IT IS NOTHING NEW AND IT HAS
ALWAYS FAILED.
THERE HAS NEVER BEEN SUCCESS.
THERE HAS ALWAYS HAD TO BE SOME
KIND OF SHORING UP OR SOME KIND
OF FRAUD THAT GOES ON WHEN IT
COMES TO THE NATURE OF ANY KIND
OF VAGUE SOCIALISM WORKING.
WE SEE IT IN THE FORMER
SOVIET UNION, CUBA, VENEZUELA,
WHEREVER IT'S TRITE IT'S FAILED
AND AS A RESULT, THEY ARE STILL
ADDICTED TO THIS NOTION THAT
THEY ARE BETTER THAN US, THAT
THEY ARE THE ONES WHO CAN MAKE
THE DECISIONS, THAT WE CAN'T,
THAT WE ARE TOO DUMB TO KNOW
THAT WE CAN'T TRUST OURSELVES
AND SO THEY ARE ADDICTED TO THIS
NOTION OF BEING OUR SUPERIORS,
TO CONTROLLING OUR MONEY, ENTER
PROVING TO THEMSELVES AS A
RESULT WAS CENTRAL PLANNING,
MASSIVE GOVERNMENT, TAKING ALL
OF OUR MONEY INTO THE NORMAL
SENSE OF PERSONAL FREEDOM,
BECAUSE OF COURSE, THEY JUST
DON'T LIKE US.
WE SEE THAT IN THE LEFT IN THEIR
ATTACK ON PRESIDENT TRUMP.
HE IS REVILED BECAUSE HE LIKES
US.
HE LIKES THIS COUNTRY.
HE WANTS IT TO DO WELL.
THAT IS WHY HE IS WHO HE IS.
>> Sean: 78 TOP% MARGINAL RATE
FOR INDIVIDUALS, 90% FOR
CORPORATIONS.
OUT OF ALL TAX TO THAT.
SAVE MONEY AFTER THEY TAKE $0.60
OFF EVERY DOLLAR.
AND THEN WHEN YOU DIE WOULD TAKE
ANOTHER 40% FOR THE DEATH TAX.
LEGALIZE STEALING, TO ME, AND IT
IS GOING TO DESTROY ANY
INCENTIVE AND THEN THE NUMBERS
DON'T ADD UP AS I WAS POINTING
OUT TO TAMI.
>> YEAH, I CAN BARELY ADD
ANYTHING TO WHAT TAMMY HAD TO
SAY.
SHE'S ABSOLUTELY SPOT ON.
BERNIE SANDERS --
HE'S ON HIS WAY OUT OF THE
PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN.
EVERYONE HAS BECOME BERNIE.
EVERYONE HAS BECOME A SOCIALIST.
EVERYONE -- BUT HE'S ON THAT
OWNS THE LABEL.
SO WITH HIS CAMPAIGN ON
FIGURATIVE LIFE SUPPORT, HE'S
SAYING I WAS A REAL SOCIALIST
BEFORE THE WHOLE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY BECAME
SOCIALIST.
YET IF ELIZABETH WARREN IS NOT A
SOCIALIST, THEN I'M AN ASTRONAUT
BECAUSE EVERYTHING WAS THAT
WARREN IS CALLING FOR HAS THE
HALLMARKS OF SOCIALISM AND SHE
UNDERSTANDS THAT STILL THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE UNDERSTAND AND
THERE GOT THAT WE ARE NOT A
COLLECTIVE SOCIETY WHERE WE TAKE
FROM THE RICH EXCLUSIVELY
TO REDISTRIBUTE BECAUSE THAT
DOES NOT WORK.
YET GREEN NEW DEAL, MEDICARE
FRAUD, AND HE MADE A GREAT POINT
ABOUT HOW SHE EXPLAINED TO PAY
FOR IT.
SHE CLAIMS SHE WILL NOT RAISE
TAXES ON THE MIDDLE CLASS YET
SHE'S GOT ABOUT THE BEST MESSAGE
DISCIPLINE I'VE EVER HEARD.
SHE SAYS YOUR MEDICARE COSTS
WILL GO DOWN BUT YOU WILL NEVER
DENY THAT SHE RAISES TAXES ON TH
DENY THAT SHE RAISES TAXES ON TE
MIDDLE CLASS.
GOOD LUCK RUNNING AGAINST
PRESIDENT TRUMP WITH THE MANTRA
OF I'M GOING TO RAISE YOUR TAXES
TO GIVE YOU GOVERNMENT RUN
HEALTH CARE AFTER THE ECONOMY
THAT THIS PRESIDENT HAS
DELIVERED.
SHE KNOWS THAT CAN'T WORK BUT IN
THE MEANTIME, SHE'S GOT A MEDIA
THAT WON'T ASK HER THOSE TOUGH
QUESTIONS.
AND I HOPE BLOOMBERG GETS IN.
NO BIG GULPS FOR ANYBODY.
>> Sean: BLOOMBERG IS A NICE
GUY BUT I DON'T EVEN DRINK BIG
GULPS.
YOU GO TO A RESTAURANT, BASALT
ON THE TABLE --
YEAH.
>> IT WAS THE ONE, ALL OF THE
ENTIRE FIELD OF THE DEMOCRATS
CONTINUE TO UNDERESTIMATE THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, THE
UNDERESTIMATE THE PRESIDENT,